weird thing is I'm ice cube we could be
related because apparently there's some
Irish stock in your past no it could be
you never know you have an Irish name do
i it couldn't be more Irish there's no
one told you that's it now but you know
I think my mother just liked the name ok
christianism yes my yep I think people
are notorious for picking things that
they saw one day and say that's my baby
name
there's no amazing story behind
that's not the case reading the paper
and she was eating cereal you are here
promoting a movie but Kevin you're
working at the same time you're doing
yeah and up gigs double dipping yes
doing a ton of stand-up shows my what
now tours here as well major thank you
to the to the UK fans the tour sold out
in like literally two days so you guys
are amazing baby back when and and then
after that we came over here for promo
with Cuba myself love doing is really
getting involved with the fans you know
we love putting our feet on the street
and really being active and interacting
so we've been doing a ton of pop-ups
yeah just delivering the movie the best
of my ability which is laughing in
person and we're splitting all the tour
mind not sure tackled me from the back
scared to live
it was one of the most frightening
moments of my life to me I think we
might have another frightening moment
for you this is a you in Manchester now
do you even know the name of that show
this picture this looks like you've been
photoshopped in Ruiz rules the house
feeds out big I grew up there
they were like rap delish Straight Outta
Compton crazy my name ice cube from
can't boycott something that you never
went to anyway that's kind of weird and
not you know it's uh I look at it as